I got home from the comedy store, I'd
like to, and then I watched some goofy,
I've been on this Ufo documentary kick
watching you a foe. Documentaries.
Yeah. I told you it was David. That was,
I'd seen it. I started talking about
it though. We were talking about that.
What were you, did you have something
specific that you saw recently?
The documentary,
one of them is air area 51 Bob Lasar
and alien area 51 and flying saucers.
It's uh,
some,
a documentary on this guy who claimed
that he worked on these alien ships in
area 51 in the 1980s and
chills as time's gone on more,
more of the things that he said
have proven to actually be true,
including an element that he talked about.
Element one 15,
I think it was called like an
organism from outer space. No, no, no.
An element like a man created element,
you know, at this carbon, right? Yeah.
Well there's an element that they created
that he talked about way before it was
ever publicized and he talked about this
thing and then it turned out to be true.
He talked about these,
um, there's these, um, uh,
hand monitors that you would put your
hand on this thing and these lines,
these metal lines would detect the
distances in the bones of your fingers,
the exact distances and
everyone is different.
It's like a signature thing and that
they could find out if it was you or not
you, it was trying to go through.
So the way they would scan people,
that bio scan would literally measure
the bones and their fingers and people
said that was horseshit. It's
all about this. In the 1980s,
people said it was horseshit,
but then later on turned
out, no, they did have that.
And Los Alamos, they did
have that in, in area 51.
And that this technology was very,
very uh,
in advance, very not just at
very advanced but very not,
it was not well known at all.
Like very few people did.
And this guy who was creative
with this documentary,
it was very difficult for them to
get photos of this hand scanner.
But this hand scanner did exist and
existed exactly as this guy described it
in the 80s. I mean that's
super progressive for that
time. It also a Plinko
that did approve is top secret
clearance to get to this place.
They know that he actually worked there.
There's people that um,
worked in the same Los
Alamos lab with him.
They tried to say he never worked there,
but his name's on the manifest.
It's very strange.
It's like they've tried to erase parts
of this guy's passed because he um,
he filmed a bunch of their crafts
as they were flying around.
Like he knew what days. This is
the thing, that thing right there,
you put your hand on that and it
actually measures the distance of your,
the size and length of your bone.
That looks like something that's
inside of an escape room in La.
[inaudible]
I went into this documentary, skeptical.
I wasn't sure. Yeah, but I am.
I'm so done with all those things.
But listen to this guy talk for awhile.
After awhile I was like,
what if he's telling the truth?
Like what if he is
actually telling the truth?
Because if he's actually
telling the truth,
there is some part of the government that
had access at least in the 19 to alien
technology.
I mean it probably is.
It probably is some truth to that.
Crazier things have happened. And also
like just your mentality of believing him.
It's probably the same thing that made
Dr Malakai Lovejoy Robinson the third
become successful. A con artist.
Yeah. I mean either this dude,
there's validity of what he's
saying in this documentary,
which I can't wait to watch or he's
just really great at painting a picture.
Some people are so good at convincing
you that's true of truths. True.
There's,
you know,
people with like borderline personality
disorder in every sort of spectrum in
between there they become
really good manipulators.
That is true. However, usually they
do that in more than one avenue.
Absolutely. And this guy's
not doing that. Yeah.
So if it's just a documentary then also
hasn't varied a story like you mean he
might've like changed the way he says
things in terms of like the words he
chooses.
But the actual story is exactly the
same as he was telling a long time ago.
Is this a self produced documentary or
is there a production company in the oil
production company? That's
where was like, hmm, okay,
there's probably some validity to this.
This guy's been around for a long time.
I remember reading about him and watch
videos about him, you know, 20 years ago.
I mean, don't you think you're
somebody who you said you, you know,
and I notice about you, you love space.
You're, you're obsessed with that.
The idea of what we are in,
in the solar system and beyond,
like how impossible is it to think that
there could be a creature that could
breach our atmosphere with some advanced
technology and be able to just sort of
chill, you know, scoot around,
scoot scoots macoutes check
us out and fucking piece out,
back up to wherever they're from.
That's how they would do it. But yeah,
I know what you're saying. Exactly.
They scoot, scoot, scoot codes. Yeah.
They just kind of cruise around.
You know, they're looking at us.
Well, he had an initial reconnaissance.
He said if you brought a um, uh,
uh,
an atomic engine to these people that
live in the Victorian era and said,
hey, this is a, this is a nuclear power
plant, like here, here, check this out.
They would fuck with it. They'd
wind up getting sick from radiation.
They'd wind up dying. No one would
understand what it was or how it worked.
They would never figure
it out. Right. He goes,
why would we assume that this is only
from that one time with this one device?
Why would we assume that there'd be
some other technology that maybe we'll
create some day in the future?
I'm paraphrasing and very poorly,
or someone else from another planet would
create that we wouldn't understand at
all.
And he said that's what we were dealing
with when we're trying to back engineer
the propulsion systems
that these things use the,
they use some gravity based propulsion
system and it was just something that
would manipulate gravity in front
of, it's very, look, I don't,
I'm too stupid to know the science of it.
I don't know if he's town,
like if you're a scientist, you're
supposed to know these things. Yeah.
I have to get my to Joseph Rogan degree
so I can call myself doctor. You should.
I just want to get an honorary one.
Like Cosby had.
Oh, it's gone now. He doesn't have it.
He doesn't have it anymore.
They
take back, take him back. He can't
keep those. He can keep that. Actually,
I think he wrote an essay and that's
why they gave him his doctorate.
I'm just neither here nor rose.
Probably got more than one doctorate.
I'm sure he did and he didn't. He
didn't deserve that. But I think,
I mean there's gotta be stuff out there.
Oh,
a hundred percent a hundred
percent I like to say there's not,
it's like, ah, stop. No,
no, I don't think it is,
but it is entirely possible.
Um,
I use that phrase too often
and it's entirely possible.
You've got to get a mash up of
all of those. It's sort of you're
hilarious. 150,000 of them. To be honest.
It's possible that we're the,
we're the most advanced.
That's possible too because something
has to be the most advanced. Absolutely.
And something has to be the least.
We could also be on that part of the
spectrum or maybe where the last two we
evolve. It's a hundred percent a
hundred percent possible. If there's,
if there's an infinite number
of life forms out there,
like if there's an infinite number of
planets and there's an infinite number of
earth, like planets that could, you
know, have beings like us on it.
Who's to say that we're
not the most advanced?
Maybe they're all like people from the
1820s they haven't caught up to the
ceiling shit. They're still doing, you
know, I don't think they chiseled chisels,
but I'm talking like old old shit.
They don't even have pens and papers yet.
Like the orangutan that
was fishing with a spirit.
There's just a bunch of advanced
orangutans that are like, you know,
putting hieroglyphics in caves.
It's possible. It is very possible.
It's totally possible.
But because we're just,
we're just basing it off of our own
experience and perception of what we have
been exposed to. We have no
idea. You know, the other, um,
really interesting scenario is
that there are time travelers. Oh,
that's really,
that's exciting to think about ar is some
being from the far distant future that
understands that it could come back and
observe us and see like where things
went wrong,
where things went right,
but do so in a way that's as minimally
intrusive as possible and occasionally
interfere.
That's things.